Я прийшов до військкомату й кажу, що мені треба.
"Влад, ти куди йдеш?"
Не тормозіть мене. Мені треба.
Ми їдемо туди й розуміємо, що може прилетіти.
"Ти крові боїшся?". Я кажу, що ні. "А, ну нормально".
Ну як це? Ну я ж так не переживу.
Оце я для себе обрав шлях, капець.
Є українські футболісти, які після вторгнення Росії
продовжили жити й працювати в Росії.
Анатолій Тимощук.
З ним я точно спілкуватись не буду.
Хай вони бояться, а не ми.
Сьогодні говоримо з українським футболістом
і бійцем Національної гвардії Владиславом Ващуком.
Пане Владиславе, вітаю вас!
Ви - футболіст із блискучою кар'єрою.
За плечима понад 10 років у національній збірній України.
І ось у травні 2023-го ви добровільно вступаєте
до Національної гвардії. Чим шокуєте своє найближче
оточення, як ви самі публічно розповідали.
Що вас спонукало до цього?
Спонукало те, що війна. Треба щось робити.
Треба робити для армії, треба робити для себе.
Я подумав, що треба прискорити цей процес,
щоб мої діти в цьому не брали участь.
Треба йти вперед. Коли була конкуренція в "Динамо",
коли була конкуренція в інших командах,
то треба було продавлювати. Так, напевно,
спортивне життя теж спонукало. А ще те,
що я був в Гостомелі два тижня в підвалі з дітьми,
там їжі було небагато. Це пережив.
І якось зловив себе на думці, що коли з дітьми виходив
з Гостомеля, то дуже переживав, а коли їхали за Куп’янськ,
в броні й з автоматом, то я якось не переживав.
Всі переживали, а я не переживав. Не ті, хто їхав зі мною,
а переживали ті, хто думали: "Ну, куди він поїхав?"
Нині ви служите в медичній роті бригади наступу "Буревій".
Розкажіть, чому саме ця рота?
Звідки взялась бригада "Буревій" в моєму житті?
Я скажу так: до мене зателефонував мій друг
Всеволод Стеблюк, він герой України, полковник.
На теперішній час він академік, полковник і мій командир.
Він запропонував мені організувати матч між "Буревієм"
і легендами футболу. А я після виходу з Гостомеля думав,
чим я можу допомогти. Треба було щось робити,
волонтерити. Я з сестрою поспілкувався,
вона об'єднала людей і зробила фонд.
Вона допомагала й допомагає нині.
Я організував гру. Знайшов спонсорів.
Хлопці, мої друзі, допомогли. Хто форму купив, м'ячі,
організували матч на стадіоні Федерації футболу іменні Баннікова.
Запросив своїх друзів, за нас грав Стаховський.
Я: "Будеш грати?" Він: "Якщо буде час".
Він приїхав і грав за нас. Так зворушливо було
організовано. Хлопці після цієї гри
одразу поїхали на Бахмут.
Потім через пару днів у Всеволода був день народження
й він каже: "Владе, а що ти? Давай до нас".
Я кажу: "Куди до вас?" "В "Буревій", в медроту".
Я: "Та в сенсі, я ж навіть не розумію, що тут робити.
Яка медрота?". Я пам’ятаю, коли лікар вибігав
на поле й питав: "Де болить? Зараз пройде".
Все.  "Та ні, все буде добре, все нормально. Давай до нас".
На той час я подумав ніч. Я нікому не казав про це.
І на наступний день я йому кажу: "Так, я готовий".
Я прийшов до військкомату й кажу, що мені треба.
"Влад, ти куди йдеш?"
Вас впізнали?
Комісар впізнав. Я кажу: "Мені треба, я йду, все!"
Я пройшов лікарів. Лікарі теж впізнали.
Я кажу: "Не гальмуйте мене. Мені треба".
І так я швидко пройшов, здав аналізи.
Прийшов, отримав форму. Коли ти приходиш за
спортивним одягом, то там адміністратор дає форму,
сумку та інше. Цього разу прийшов,
а тут військова форма. Було дуже схоже.
До речі, така паралель.
Я теж, коли готувалася до інтерв'ю, то думала про те,
що ви з Національної збірної - до Національної гвардії…
Ну так, я ось сиджу в спорті, а тут уже в армії.
Таке буває, це нормально. Потім я склав присягу.
Був час, коли я навчався й готувався:
і стріляли ми, і бігали, і навчалися турнікети накладати,
як судину знаходити в животі, як перекривати.
Насамперед це було і для мене.
Я не розумів, що мені треба робити.
А потім уже поїхав на евакуацію.
Я кажу: "А що там робити?" "Спостерігай".
І так потрохи, не через теорію, а через практику,
прийшов до того, що наразі я вже зробив понад 50 евакуацій.
Розкажіть, що входить у ваші обов'язки
як бійця медичної роти?
Адже не всі розуміють, що таке медична рота та як вона функціонує.
Ми виїжджаємо туди. Там, де наші бригади,
ми організовуємо мобільні госпіталі -
медпункти, де приймають з різними пораненнями,
бувають застуди, бувають травми.
Хлопці там крапаються, а потім повертаються назад.
Є "штабік", де приймають дуже тяжких.
Є різні кейси. З поля бою й одразу в "штабік".
Ну, це "нуль". Моя задача наразі: я їжджу туди,
куди скажуть, забираю поранених і відводжу в госпіталь.
Робимо все для того, щоб поновити стан наших поранених.
Ви вже згадували Всеволода Стеблюка,
вашого командира. Я читала його інтерв'ю,
в якому він дуже тепло про вас відгукувався.
Його слова: "Сьогодні, коли на евакуації кажуть,
що в поїзді Ващук, це значить, що Гвардія забере
свого пораненого бійця якісно, швидко і професійно".
Він каже, що я багато бачу навкруги й можу
зорієнтуватися швидше, ніж люди, які цього не бачать.
Я це застосовую, й коли хтось дивиться за одним,
я дивлюсь за всіма. На полі, коли грав,
у нас же грало 11 чоловік.
Треба аналізувати як своїх, так і чужих, чужу команду.
Так і я роблю цю справу. Де можна зробити якісніше,
щоб хлопцям було зручніше, то ми робимо.
Спочатку я в командира питаю: "А що робити?"
Він питає: "Ти крові боїшся?" Я кажу, що ні.
"А, ну нормально". Але ж він не сказав про все інше.
А кров же зупиняють там, щоб військовий не загинув.
Бо кров вийде і все. А вони вже приїжджають
в різному стані. Ти радієш, коли поранений виходить сам.
Так, у нього є якісь переломи, але він сам виходить.
І ти так радієш: "Ой, клас".
Розкажіть, наскільки ваша робота є небезпечною?
Адже я зустрічала інформацію про те, що росіяни
навмисно полюють на українські евакуаційні екіпажі.
Прилетіти може всюди.
Якось я про це взагалі не думаю.
Те, що хтось думає, що когось чи не зачепить,
чи пройде повз, чи що ми в безпеці, такого не буває.
Ми їдемо туди й розуміємо, що може прилетіти.
І багато буває поранених. Не без цього, це війна.
Багато хто сьогодні думає, що війна якось йде не так.
Хтось каже про якийсь глухий кут.
Війна - це не глухий кут. Це - війна.
Ми з вами розмовляємо в Києві.
Я так розумію, що у вас зараз невелика пауза
між бойовими завданнями?
Ну так, сьогодні трошки пауза, так вдалося.
Ви приїхали до столиці…
Я вчора приїхав.
Я правильно розумію, ще вчора ви були на бойову завданні?
Розумієте, можна по-різному казати.
Для мене це моя робота і я її роблю.
Перші евакуації були тяжкі для мене психологічно.
Я думаю: "Оце я для себе обрав шлях, капець".
Я після кожної евакуації приходив мокрий.
Мені треба було посидіти, поміркувати.
Думав: "Ну, як це? Ну, я ж так не переживу". Це дуже тяжко.
А потім я питаю командира: "Командире, а як ви всі такі,
ніби відморожені? Я не розумію.
Як мені таким стати, щоб не переживати, не нести це?"
А потім я згадав, як казав Лобановський:
"15 хвилин радієш, 15 хвилин хвилюєшся після гри". І все.
Наступна гра. Так і я: зробив свою справу
і перемикаюсь швидше. Треба перемикатись.
До речі, як вас змінив цей досвід?
Хм, не знаю… Намагаюсь посміхатися,
намагаюсь залишатися тим, ким був.
Час йде й час такий напружений.
Тяжкувато. Міняюсь, якось міняюсь.
Я розумію, що ми не можемо говорити про якісь конкретні
локації, але все-таки: ви працюєте на фронті
й на прифронтових територіях?
Так, я всюди працюю. Куди скаже командир - туди й їдемо.
"А можна не їхати? А можна…?"
Там такого нема.
Розкажіть про те, який настрій в українських військових,
ви ж з ними спілкуєтеся. В якому вони стані загалом?
По кожному, кого ми забираємо…
Він каже: "Я командир підрозділу, мені треба повертатися".
Я кажу: "Треба відновитися насамперед".
А він уже завтра готовий їхати далі давати бій.
Сьогодні настрій воювати - у всіх.
Хто там побував, то хотіли б повернутися.
Очі горять, очі хочуть, щоб у нас була перемога і тільки перемога.
Коли ви забираєте з фронту пораненого військового,
що ви йому кажете? Як ви його підтримуєте?
А я його не підтримую. Він сам каже все.
Я запитав, з якого він напрямку і все.
Він сам каже: "Так, там трохи була підстава.
Та вони самі в шоці були, що ми так далеко зайшли".
Загалом хлопці дуже потужні. Поранені, але потужні.
Вони бачать, що їх зустрічають, їх переносять.
Вони вдома. Вдома. Ми вдома. Це до нас прийшли.
Розумієте, сусіди повинні спілкуватися, рухатися,
домовлятися. А коли сусід бачить в нас здобич,
то треба захищатися. І ми захищаємо свою націю,
своє життя й свою країну. Я прийшов для того,
щоб мої діти цього не бачили й в цьому не брали участь.
А хто ще з українських футболістів нині на фронті?
На думку спадає хіба Олександр Алієв.
Алієв з перших днів. Він же росіянин,
а вже тут став українцем, який захищає Україну від Росії.
На самому початку багато хто…
Допомагає багато й Тарас Михалик.
Каже, що теж би пішов, але його не пускають.
Кажуть: "Ти тут багато можеш нам допомогти,
ми за тебе повоюємо". Він їздить, я бачу, регулярно.
Федецький їздить. Багато хто телефонує мені з передку,
зі штабів. Вони хочуть поспілкуватися.
Вони кажуть: "Заїжджай до нас, трошки поспілкуємось".
Я кажу: "Без питань, але я ж не сам, я ж солдат.
Куди скаже командир - туди й поїдемо.
Я ж не на прогулянку до вас їду". Ну, вони розуміють.
Я би поїздив так по фронту, по лінії й поспілкувався б.
Якщо я можу підтримати, то я готовий.
І багато хлопців-футболістів готові поїхати й підтримати.
Але все ж переважна більшість футболістів
допомагають як волонтери, беруть участь
у різноманітних благодійних матчах.
І ми організовуємо матчі, і наша медична рота грає.
І я думаю, що і в наступному році будемо організовувати,
і є пропозиції різні.
Я для нашої роти організував форму.
Сьогодні я допомагаю своїй роті,
ми ростемо в плані комфорту для наших бійців.
Проте є українські футболісти, які після вторгнення
Росії продовжили жити й працювати в Росії.
Приміром, ваш колега по національній збірній
Анатолій Тимощук.
Як ви відреагували на таку позицію
окремих українських футболістів?
Ніяк не відреагував. Тоді, коли я виходив з Гостомеля,
мені це питання поставили.
Я кажу: "Дайте мені трохи часу, щоб хоча б зрозуміти, де я.
Бо коли ти знаходишся в підвалі й вийшов,
то тоді це взагалі не моє питання".
Уже пройшов час і ви запитуєте, це точно не моє питання.
У кожного свій шлях. З ним я точно спілкуватись не буду.
Ви зараз трохи згадали про ваш досвід перших двох
тижнів у Гостомелі. Коли почалося вторгнення,
ви були з родиною вдома?
Так, з родиною. Я і двоє дітей.
І два тижні ви просиділи в підвалі?
Так. Так, як я, можна сказати, сам живу з дітьми.
Як зазвичай у неодруженого чоловіка буває небагато їжі.
Треба було спілкуватися й знаходити їжу.
Потім заїхав мер до нас, коли розбомбили "Новус".
І  вони привезли трошки їжі.
Все спілкування було на вулиці.
Коли не було зв'язку, вся інформація була тільки на вулиці:
кого підбили, де стріляють, де ходять.
Вночі таке враження було, що навіть комарі
не літали не було жодного шуму.
Вночі ми з сином мінялись й ходили з міркувань безпеки.
У вас дорослий син?
Так, на той час було 19 років, а доньці - 13.
Вам вдалося виїхати. Як?
Три дні була електрика, потім не було.
На 10 день не було газу, ми готували на дровах.
Мене рятувало, що в мене була кава не в зернах.
Її можна було робити на багатті.
У сусідів взяв чайник. Так і підігрівали воду,
так і готували їсти для себе. 10 числа ми виходили.
Ми зустріли хлопців, які кажуть:
"Давайте виїжджати разом". Я кажу: "Давайте я заберу
автівку й поїдемо всі разом".
І ми так стали на моїй вулиці. Я виїхав з гаражу.
Стали й за нами теж багато автівок стало.
Хлопці просто знали те, як виїжджати.
Треба було не так виїжджати, як раніше, бо мосту не було.
І ми поїхали. Обв’язали автівку свою білими
простирадлами, написали "Діти" і поїхали.
Рухалися, багато було вбитих, уламків.
Я думав, що якщо проб’ю колеса,
то все одно буду рухатися в напрямку виїзду.
І син каже: "Тато, там снайпер сидить".
І ми так потихеньку їхали, десь кілометрів 20 на годину.
Багато руйнувань, багато. Я казав доньці, щоб не дивилась.
Чотири блокпости росіян проїхали.
Вони нас не зупиняли, а до цього зупиняли всіх,
забирали телефони. Але ми позаховували.
Я вийшов, а через три дні до мене в будинок "зайшли"
два бронетранспортера російських і понад 15
чоловік були в мене вдома.
Вони у вас жили?
Так, жили. У мене злість й ненависть.
І я розумію, що не треба, спокійно.
Я дуже переживав за це. Але що робити?
Я вже нічого б не зробив. Вони там бухали.
Вони переживали, щоб їх не побачили й заставили вікна.
Води ж нема, дома був вінегрет.
Костюм збірної України вони повісили,
думали, може, забрати. І вони так мою фотографію
з дітьми поставили й так типу з нами бухали.
Ось така зустріч у вас із росіянами відбулася у 2022 році.
Але ж 20 років тому ви жили в Росії якийсь час теж.
Якщо я не помиляюсь, у 2003-му ви підписали контракт
з московським "Спартаком",
але у вас там щось не склалося
й ви досить швидко звідти пішли.
Так.
Чим запам'ятався вам той період і життя в Росії загалом?
Після Гостомеля вже нічим не запам'ятався.
Це було колись. Розумієте, коли прийшла війна,
то є "до" і "після". Те, що було "до" вже не має жодного
сенсу в сьогоднішньому житті.
Сьогодні я військовий, сьогодні я захищаю свою країну
під прапором. І не на футбольному полі, а на нашій землі.
На вашу думку, спорт може бути поза політикою?
Ні, сьогодні ні. Я розумію, що якщо аналізувати,
то футбол - це інструмент для того, щоб рухатися
частково по політиці. І якщо якась країна щось
робить не так, то вона через спорт може це нівелювати.
Зробити так, щоби ніхто не сприймав державу як агресора.
На початку грудня Міжнародний олімпійський комітет
ухвалив рішення допустити російських та білоруських
атлетів до Олімпійських ігор під нейтральним прапором.
Як ви відреагували на цю новину?
На вашу думку, чи є місце росіянам
і білорусам у міжнародному спорті?
Я не розумію російських спортсменів,
які поїдуть на Олімпіаду чи Чемпіонат світу.
Я не розумію, навіщо вони це будуть робити.
Бо не тільки Україна, а й увесь світ буде це бачити.
Що вони хочуть до нас донести?
Вони прийшли з війною до нас. І вони хотіли б десь там,
може, в Парижі чи в Ірландії, чи в Ісландії,
хотіли б спілкуватися? З ними немає спілкування.
Йдіть геть з нашої країни і все. Нашим спортсменам
треба їхати. Хай вони бояться, а не ми.
І нам треба брати участь. І Олімпійський комітет,
і всі комітети повинні зробити для себе висновок,
що ми повинні брати участь в цих змаганнях.
Для чого? Для того, щоб вони не приїхали.
Ким ви бачите себе після завершення війни?
Я не можу забігти за війну. Сьогодні війна.
Я не знаю, наскільки вона буде довгою чи швидкою.
Як тільки я буду розуміти, що все добре,
я вам розповім про плани, які будуть.
Вони швидко сплануються.
А що б ви сказали тим, хто вагається:
вступати до війська чи ні?
А також тим, хто намагається уникнути мобілізації?
Дивіться, якщо б прийшли росіяни,
то вони б мобілізували усіх.
Зробили б армію, хватали б. І всі, хто б верещали,
що не можуть, всі б воювали.
Треба перемогти й для цього треба зробити все.
Якщо ти хочеш перемогти і є бажання майбутнього
своїй дитині, то треба йти і рухатись
у напрямку перемоги. Не боятися того,
що тебе десь знайдуть, десь притащать.
Йти у військкомат і казати: "Я хочу".
Всі думають, що у нас хватають й вивозять туди,
мовляв, давайте воюйте. Такого нема.
Всі навчаються, всі отримують якусь освіту.
Як поводитись з автоматом. Якщо ти хочеш.
Я захотів і я рухаюсь в цьому напрямку.
Я хочу допомагати тим, чим можу.
І я бачу, що наша медрота теж потребує людей.
Нас не вистачає так, щоб допомогти всім.
Тому ми йдемо цим напрямком, і люди бачать,
і вони йдуть до нас. Не треба чекати,
коли вас приведуть за ручку, йдіть самі.
Пане Владиславе, дякую вам за цю розмову.
Дякую!